how's it going
anime lovers hope you're having an
amazing day and if not
that's about to change because i've got
something very special for you with this
decade coming to an end today we'll be
looking at some of the best and most
impactful anime fights we've witnessed
throughout the past 10 years
so get cozy and prepare yourself let's
go
[Music]
we start off with one of the most iconic
fights from the dragon ball franchise
goku vs jiren
obviously this list wouldn't be complete
without dragon ball in it now would it
despite what the artsy and selective
anime fan may tell you
creating a shonen battle is a form of
art having said that goku vs jiren's
easily one of the flashiest fights in
dragon ball history when the two finally
clash
goku's outmatched big time jiren
surprises goku by turning his spirit
bomb against him
and just as things look over goku
miraculously unlocks his most powerful
transformation yet
the ultra instinct surprisingly though
jiren defeats goku effortlessly and
thankfully the rematch isn't that far
away
after all it's the fate of the universe
kind of [ __ ] that we're talking about
that's on the line
so goku finally masters ultra instinct
overall this fight made me feel like a
kid again i got flashbacks of when i saw
goku vs frieza for the first time in dbz
this has to be one of the coolest
memorable and inspiring fights in all of
dragon ball
that won't be forgotten anytime soon
next it's jotaro vs dio from jojo's
bizarre adventure stardust crusaders
as for this being jojo's number one
fight hardcore fans might put this on
their own list of best fights in anime
because it's a pure mix of brain
brawn and balls to the walls after
emerging from the shadows dio's back but
this time with his op
stand ability the world which can freeze
time minimally
but enough to do some maximum damage the
fight goes all around the streets of
cairo causing mayhem they push each
other to the brink and it eventually
comes down to wits
in one instance when jotaro's knocked
down from a knife attack he purposely
stops his heart from beating
just to play possum and throws a
devastating sucker punch before dio can
freeze time just when you think it's all
over though
dio finds a way to come back eventually
he lets himself get knocked around back
to joseph's body to absorb his blood to
go full power but that's not enough to
stop my boy joe taro as he angrily
shatters dio's body to pieces
by stopping his roundhouse kick with a
devastating overhand right swing
at eight we have arguably the best fight
from one piece yet
luffy versus katakuri now i know a lot
of people had some doubts around one
piece following
its time skip but there's no arguing the
awesomeness in the fight between luffy
and the sweet commander katakuri this is
definitely one of the major highlights
of the series as a whole and a major
upset
for the latter half of the series as
luffy tries to rescue sanji from whole
cake island
he comes face to face with someone he
deems his greatest test for advancing as
a pirate
charlotte katakuri whose abilities are
similar to luffy's but more powerful in
every regard during the fight they begin
respecting each other and develop as
people and fighters
it's an amazing fight in the manga and
the great animation in the anime is
definitely worth any fan going out of
their way to see
just like all the others on this list
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
at number five we have ichigo versus
okiyora
ichigo's long-running rivalry with the
emotionless
okiyora finally comes to an end in
dramatic over-the-top fashion
just the way we like it all kiyora has
proven to be one of ichigo's toughest
opponents
the audience was put in real suspense
when all kiora landed a successful sero
ascuras on ichigo but alkiora had no
idea he'd just signed his own death
sentence with the attack by helping
ichigo take on his newest
powerful and terrifying hollow form this
is the moment when the two swap places
with ichigo's new form revealing his
deep demonic nature
and all kiara's first experience with
fear proving that he's just as flawed as
the humans he looks on from above the
fight is epic
seeing how faster and unpredictable
ichigo is compared to all kiara when
he's transformed making it a living hell
for him
[Music]
the next fights from a series known for
its amazing fights
yes it's kiritsugu vs kirei from fate
zero
most people think major climatic anime
fights must have over the top crazy
action full of destructive attacks
big speeches and loads of screaming
leaving little room for originality
it's rare that the fight only contains
two total hits and no dialogue
but still remains compelling and
interesting this one achieves just that
two of the most important characters in
the fate series kirei and kiritsugu
battle it out as foils
two people cut from the same cloth
pragmatic monsters who are beyond right
or wrong in their personal crusades now
fluid fight choreography and brilliant
strategizing highlight the rather short
confrontation between two people
who are essentially the same which you
can see in their exchanges
despite being this badass mage killer
who doesn't give a damn about fighting
clean and honorably kiritsugu finds his
match in the priest
who acts as a war that he can't overcome
but overall
the fight's amazing and personally this
is my favorite fight from the fate
franchise
next on the list it's naruto vs sasuke
of course this list wouldn't be complete
without the fans favorite frenemies
naruto and sasuke
these two have been close friends rivals
and to some extent
enemies as well their fight starts in
the final valley where they exchange
their ideas and beliefs about the world
sasuke wants to start a revolution by
killing five car gays in charge of the
five hidden villages
naruto of course disagrees and tells him
he's taking the wrong path
seeing two close friends fight with
everything they have throwing their most
powerful
jutsus at one another was heart crushing
but we knew it was only a matter of time
before this happened anyway
this fight was amazingly well
choreographed and those flashbacks
really made us all emotional in the end
sasuke's chidori and naruto's racing gun
collided
resulting in a big explosion causing
both of them to lose a hand
lying down on the ground sasuke admits
defeat
even after all of sasuke's [ __ ] naruto
still wasn't willing to give up on him
that's what
real friends do and thankfully sasuke
acknowledged that
[Music]
for those who haven't seen gintama
you're probably surprised to see this
fight so high on the list but for me
personally
this is one of my favorite fights in all
of anime
that's right peeps gintama's a lot more
than just a comedy anime
this fight's raw and bloody just what
you'd expect from a great samurai vs
samurai fight
we finally get takasugi's point of view
who's not so different from gentoki
after all
but just a victim of tragic circumstance
as shown in their backstory they've
actually almost fought each other
500 times they head towards each other
screaming leaving a side tactic or
strategy they know each other inside out
their fighting styles weaknesses what
they're capable of
both have been waiting for this moment
for years and when they finally meet
they're left with nothing else to do but
unleashing the rage they've been honing
in all these years
they're evenly matched every kick and
punch thrown is immediately returned to
the other when takasugi stabs gintoki
then kentoki stabs takasugi
is something like a mirrored pvp match
where you fight your twin brother or
something like that
[Music]
and number one we have without a doubt
one of the best fights in the hunter
hunter anime and anime in general
it's netero vs meruem a fight that's
even hyped more by the epic soundtrack
and the awesome narrator
delivering an epic showdown between
natero and the chimera and king meruem
leaving aside the incredibly crisp and
amazing animation in the fight itself
more importantly this is about the
ideological conflict and what it means
to be a human
meruem's probably my favorite anime
villain of all time he's a complex
character that initially starts as your
typical cruel and violent dictator
that considers himself superior to all
other forms of life he felt no concern
for his dying mother after his birth
and he only shows respect towards the
strong and has no empathy towards humans
viewing them as nothing but a source of
food later on however
after meeting komugi meruem started to
question the differences between
ants and mankind and battled with his
identity as half human and half
insect questioning the nature of
violence and strength as true power
on the opposite corner stands nadero
fighting to save humanity from
extinction
that and well because he really just
likes a good old fight natero dedicated
his life to martial arts
similarly to the king he displayed a
great deed of pride when it comes to his
own abilities
his goal in life is to find a worthy
adversary that he can fight with his
whole spirit
they both admire and acknowledge each
other as worthy opponents though it
looks like the fight could go either way
with no clear indication who's
ultimately going to win
soon enough we see that the king sees
hulls in the thero's patterns
taking advantage of them to get through
the hands of his stand i mean
bodhisattva nadero's mistake initially
costs him his right leg
but the old man continues to fight
brushing it off like no big deal calling
it
just a lucky punch after that if this
old man isn't the biggest badass in the
show then i don't know who is
the king's physical superiority against
nadero's superior will
is like a battle between an unstoppable
force and an immovable object
in the end it seems that the king got
the best of him and just as we think
this at the end
netera reveals that he had a final trick
up his sleeve
the miniature rose his final trump card
that he uses symbolically
unleashing his deeply buried menace
within his heart to nuke the whole
god damn field along with meruem
so which is your favorite anime fight of
this decade comment below if you enjoyed
the video give it a thumbs up subscribe
to the channel and if you want to see
more badass videos like this one
hit the notification bell so you never
miss out on the next ones i'll see you
next time
on videotube
[Music]
me